in san francisco we've got some
established brains at the table
we don't know what they're going to do i
don't think they know what they're going
to do let's hear a little bit
from earlier today general manager john
lynch head coach kyle shanahan
on the third overall pick in the draft
that they acquired via trade several
weeks ago
everyone has you know in your contract
you do this the draft is is mine but i
told kyle from
the beginning that this is he and i are
doing this together and when it comes to
quarterbacks
i'd be foolish i believe we have a head
coach who's also our offensive play
caller i will always defer to him
and you know what's cool about that is
that kyle i think respects my opinion
enough
he always wants it and ultimately we
arrive at decisions
uh we will and come thursday we'll have
a pick that uh hopefully makes everyone
proud but that will be judged in years
to come
you know we knew that there was three at
the time exactly that's why we thought
three was
a good spot to go to after going through
this whole process i feel good about
five guys at three
um yeah we had a guy probably at first
back then
but we knew that wasn't set in stone
yeah we probably started with one in
mind but
that one's gotten better since and so of
all the other candidates
um so do we know exactly who we want
maybe
probably but maybe not i i don't feel
like
i don't feel like we need to say that
and that's not just for
our case but like you know lots of stuff
happens between now and the draft and i
don't
you don't want the whole league knowing
exactly what you're set on four days
before the draft
you know peter i understand everything
they're saying but i
am confounded perplexed and flummoxed
by the reality that this team packaged
the 12th overall pick two future first
rounders
third round pick to go up into a spot
where
they apparently didn't know what they
were gonna do three days before the
draft
they don't seem to know what they're
gonna do the benefit is they're getting
plenty of attention we're gonna talk
about the 49ers continuously for the
next three days
but at some point you look
wishy-washy you look hesitant you look
like you moved up to three before you
really had a plan like maybe they
thought the panthers were going to make
the jump instead so they figured we'd
better do it or we're going to lose the
chance
we'll figure out later who we're going
to take i really am surprised that
they're pushing back so hard
against the logical conclusion that they
had one guy in mind when they moved up
there
they're trying to create the impression
they had five guys in mind
well i would disagree with you
and say this that in my opinion
i think they made this trade exactly one
month
before the first round they made it on
march 29th
and i believe that at that time
kyle shanahan had a very good idea who
he wanted to pick
uh with that pick in the draft and
but he said hey look i am going to do my
due diligence
on the other two quarterbacks in this
draft
and i am going to give it a fair
run and he's gone to the pro day for
trey lance
he's gone to the pro day for justin
fields you know the second one of each
and so what he has done is he has done
exactly what
john lynch and adam peters and
jed york and perak marate
uh you know the brain trust of the 49ers
he has done what they wanted him to do
which is
to be fair this is a gigantic decision
that's going
to affect all of our lives and
all of our jobs so kyle shanahan has
done that
has he changed his mind for march 29 i
don't know
we'll find out on thursday night but
the other thing is uh i
believe they know what they're doing i
believe they know who they're going to
pick
and they might go through a few more
meetings to just say hey
are we sure but i would be very
surprised if right now they don't know
who they're gonna pick
do you believe that there was any type
of
fracture any type of split of opinion
where some in the organization wanted to
go
one way like with a trey lance we're
hearing bits and pieces of that now
shanahan always mac jones others like
john lynch
and adam peters pushing trey lance do
you believe do you know have you heard
do you sense
that some of that went on before they
got to where they are
i've heard that mike but i don't know if
it's true
and you know again i think i'm probably
hearing what other people are hearing
one
uh person who knows people in that
organization told me that he thought it
was 60 40 mac jokes
and if that's the case then
uh and again mike i don't know if that
is true this is just what one person
who's got some tentacles in that
organization told me
so i don't feel great about it but i
think it's
interesting and could well be true but
i guess i would make this point to you
okay
it is exactly the same thing that i saw
in 2017
when i was in their draft room and i saw
kyle shanahan he wanted a young running
back named joe williams
and joe williams wasn't on their draft
board because of all field problems
and he told john lynch before day three
of the draft
i really want joe williams lynch looked
at it again he called joe williams he
talked to him
and the whole thing is john said to
to kyle you got joe williams we're gonna
draft him
you hear what he said in that clip two
minutes ago
where he said listen my offensive play
caller should have a
big role in determining who's going to
be calling his offensive play
who he's going to be calling his
offensive plays into
and it was the same thing with joe
williams and so
to me i believe at the end of the day
unless it's five against one
you know where the only person who likes
uh
you know mac jones is kyle shane and
again i'm not positive that kyle
shanahan hasn't changed his mind
i don't know whether he has my feeling
is that he probably has it but i don't
know that the 49ers have done a very
good job
in keeping a lid on this i think they're
going to take mac jones
i will not be surprised if they take
somebody else
i was on kmbr today the 49ers flagship
and we were hashing out
how we got here and where we go from
here and peter
i think there's a rabbit hole that's
been
not completely explored as to what
happened in 2017 when
kyle shanahan was convinced he was
getting kirk cousins in free agency in
early 2018
and then boom they trade for jimmy
garoppolo john lynch says that kyle was
in mourning with a u
after that happened i'd love to know how
they convinced kyle to sign off
on the garoppolo trade when he knew when
he believed
when he thought he was getting kirk
cousins without having to give up a
draft pick
a few months later and whether or not
that same process is going on here you
know shanahan's in charge
but i almost feel like there are forces
in that organization that know how to
let
shanahan come to a decision on his own
that is influenced by others who are
trying to get him to do something other
than what he wants to do if that makes
any sense whatsoever
well the reason why i believe
that the garoppolo cousins thing was the
bird in hand is better
you know than whatever that stupid
cliche is
but the reason why i think they did that
at the time then
is that they were high on garoppolo also
as belichick was and they're they were
close to belichick and all that
and there was no guarantee they were
getting kirk cousins they might get them
but there was no guarantee that they
would get them so
i think that was exceedingly logical
back in 2017 what they did
and then mike in this particular case i
just think
if you trust kyle shanahan
to coach your quarterback and to bring
your quarterback along
and and look the last two seasons
he has had one quarterback for the full
season who he wanted you know
one was uh you know matt ryan his last
year
in in atlanta where they obviously
went to the super bowl and almost won it
and then the other one was in 2019 with
jimmy garoppolo
where they got a 10-point lead in the
fourth quarter of the super bowl
and and so in both cases
kyle shanahan coached a quarterback
to probably beyond what most people
thought that quarterback
would ever accomplish and that
is why if you were the 49ers in my
opinion
if kyle shanahan is rock solid
in the corner of mack jones you pick him
and if he's rock solid in the corner
of of the if either of the other guys
i think you pick him too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports